hola
[Música]
[Aplausos]
no no
[Música]
h
muchas gracias eso que acaba de pasar
se llama costumbre todos aquí algunos lo
dijeron otros lo pensaron salud las
costumbres son reacciones automáticas
que tenemos a situaciones específicas y
se nos van inculcando desde pequeños
ahora un niño chiquito lo primero que
dice no es salud más bien le pregunta a
su mamá cómo porque está irritado si
señor o porque de repente me cayó agua
porque siempre está la persona que no se
tapaba la boca y te caía todo el
estornudo entonces según los expertos yo
comparto cinco miedos con todos los aquí
presentes el miedo a morir a la soledad
a la mutilación a la pérdida de la
autonomía y al daño al ego sin embargo
yo no estoy del todo de acuerdo porque
porque creo que olvidarán los más
importantes por ejemplo el miedo a la
oscuridad que algunos seguimos teniendo
otros ya no el miedo a los fantasmas o
al coco en mi caso
a dar un aspecto que hablar en público y
que se me olvide todo
entonces
los miedos nos frenan muchísimo
lo que pasa es
un ejemplo muy claro de un miedo que nos
asalta a todos los días es cuando no
encuentras el celular no lo sientes no
lo sientes y te empiezas a asfixiar no
sabes qué hacer te da un ataque de
pánico y luego te das cuenta que lo
sabes en la mano y te preguntas de qué
me sirve el miedo solo no puedo pensar
con claridad y me preocupo demasiado
entonces yo me hice esa misma pregunta y
me y descubrí que el miedo en sí es un
mecanismo de supervivencia nos ayuda a
alejarnos de situaciones que percibimos
como peligrosas para la vida misma
entonces donde se genera el miedo se
genera en la vida la cerebral y ésta se
encarga de administrarnos todas nuestras
emociones más irracionales forma parte
del sistema límbico y también está
conformado por el tálamo el hipotálamo y
el hipocampo el hipocampo es bastante
importante en esta ecuación porque
porque activa el sistema nervioso
simpático no más simpático que yo pero
este sistema inició una reacción en
cadena en todo el cuerpo
primero científicamente comprobado se
supone que tus pulmones están tratando
de inhalar mucho más oxígeno con cada
respiración sin embargo a ti no te
entran nada sientes que te asfixias no
puedes respirar luego se te seca la
garganta después de un susto muy fuerte
te dan unas ganas de vomitar gigantes
porque tu sistema digestivo deja de
gastar energía que se puede usar por
ejemplo cuando se aceleran los latidos
del corazón y se agilice el sistema
circulatorio ahora todas estas
reacciones son para que mi cuerpo se
prepara para enfrentar una situación
peligrosa ya sea huyendo o luchando
contra ella entonces no vine a hablarles
de reacciones químicas en el cerebro qué
aburrido en sí vine a hablarles de una
pregunta que me está molestando bastante
porque si todas estas reacciones se
supone que me ayudan a salir corriendo
lo más rápido por ejemplo cuando me
persigue un león porque tengo las mismas
reacciones cuando se trata de pedir un
trabajo invitar a salir a alguien cuando
llego a una nueva escuela y le temo el
rechazo a fallar oa fracasar
tengo mucho miedo de darme cuenta de que
en este momento estoy envejeciendo y no
puedo hacer nada para evitarlo y ustedes
dirán tiene 16 años y ya que sabe
envejecer pero en sí el tiempo no espera
nadie el tiempo va a pasar y yo no puedo
hacer nada tengo miedo y que mañana todo
se acabe y no haya hecho ni el 70% de
todas las cosas que quería hacer y de
verdad quiero hacer esas cosas entonces
veo estos escenarios que se repiten y se
repiten en mi cabeza y me paralizan no
sé qué hacer
pongamos un caso hipotético mandó una
solicitud para el trabajo de mis sueños
en la entrevista perfecto puedo hacer
esto voy el día de la entrevista me paro
temprano ya escogí mi ropa antes voy
todo preparado y salgo muy temprano de
mi casa
en el camino como tengo tiempo paso por
un café no pasa nada
llegó la cafetería y la línea está muy
larga
bueno no importa no pasa nada tengo
tiempo entonces no es pero me da en mi
café veo la hora y es super tarde salgo
corriendo y corriendo corro y corro y
corro pero ya llegó la entrevista
todo perfecto espero que me llamen y
cuando lo hacen no veo un escalón se me
cae todo el café encima tengo que ir
corriendo al hospital con quemaduras de
tercer grado en todo el cuerpo y la cara
y termino viéndome así
todo por mandar una solicitud quien aquí
sí quien aquí no mandaría la solicitud
y ese es exactamente el punto todos
estos escenarios son improbables y de
todas maneras dejamos que nos detengan
qué pasaría si sale mal la pregunta del
millón qué pasaría si en este contexto
bastante negativa no lo creen porque nos
dice todas las cosas que pueden fallar
qué pasaría si me cae un meteorito
cuando voy caminando hacia la entrevista
qué pasaría si me roban el coche
mientras estoy consiguiendo la
entrevista qué pasaría si no me dan el
trabajo si no lo logro si no soy lo
suficientemente bueno
en sí sin el contexto negativo la
pregunta es bastante curiosa
si se dan cuenta nos invita a saber más
que hay más allá de esa barrera que nos
impone el miedo
entonces qué pasaría si sale bien
o si sale mal no termine en un desastre
tan grande como terminar con la cara
quemada pero sale mal lo puedo tachar de
mi lista no es cierto no vale la pena
intentarlo una cosa menos por hacer
entonces la curiosidad siempre es
atribuida a la gente metiche la gente
que no se conforma con la primera
respuesta
la gente que no escoge el camino más
fácil yo en si no lo considero un mal
objetivo ustedes se preguntarán por qué
en fin si nos ponemos a analizar a todos
los metiches que ha habido a lo largo de
la historia podemos ver por ejemplo que
algunos se preguntaron qué pasaría si el
camino fuera la paz
también qué pasaría si la música pudiera
ser una arquitectura de sonidos
qué pasaría si todos viviéramos en un
cosmos integral si todos tuviéramos que
estar unidos todos ellos y muchos más
navegaron en compañía de la curiosidad
hasta hoy por ejemplo alexander von
humboldt con sus investigaciones sigue
impactando al mundo el predijo muchas
cosas que iban a pasar y hoy son una
realidad él se fue américa buscó fósiles
estudió plantas y tuvo que averiguar
cómo las fuerzas de la naturaleza actúan
unas sobre otras
en resumen tuvo que aprender acerca de
la armonía de la naturaleza entonces las
investigaciones los logros la música de
todas estas personas las ideas siguen
revolucionando al mundo hoy yo los
invito a
volverse lo suficientemente metiches
para preguntarse qué pasaría si hoy
todos dejáramos de tener miedo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]